okay we begin here a few weeks ago a man
named Robert Fuller was found hanging
from a tree in Southern California and
this precipitated weeks of speculation
by the media fire stoking by Democrats
and left protests the Left speculated or
just openly outright stated that Fuller
was lynched despite the fact that the
police right away said that this is
suicide and they could tell because
police respond unfortunately to a lot of
suicide suicides very common in this
country becoming more common and it's
it's usually easy to determine and
differentiate a suicide from a murder
most of the time you know it the suicide
scene in a murder scene do not look the
same most of the time especially to
police who do this kind of thing all the
time and yet we were still told no this
is probably a lynching well in response
to the outrage police did a more
thorough investigation I think they did
the kind of investigation where they
went further than they would for any
other suicide but they did and here were
their findings from The Daily News it
says the death of a black man found
hanging from a tree in a southern
California city last month was ruled a
suicide Los Angeles County Sheriff Alex
Villanueva promised a thorough
investigation at a news conference to
announce the findings it was revealed
that fuller had a history of mental
illness and suicidal tendencies
sheriff's commander Chris marks outlined
three hospitalizations since 2017 or
fuller told doctors he was considering
taking his life the last was in November
when he was being treated for depression
at a hospital in Nevada and said that he
had a plan to kill himself
Mark's also said that there was an
investigation into an incident where
fuller allegedly tried to light himself
on fire also and this is important I
don't think it's covered in this article
but fuller used an EBT card to buy the
very rope that was used in the hanging
okay so it's conclusive there was there
was no signs of a struggle to begin with
his hands were not bound no signs that
anything occurred against his will
it's open-and-shut case closed very sad
story tragic not a story of a murder
there was never any reason to think so
and there were a lot of very clear
reasons to think otherwise a special
now but but you notice how the family
said that they can't imagine that fuller
would have killed himself meanwhile he
was hospitalized three times because he
was thinking about killing himself he
tried to set himself on fire a few
months ago allegedly did the family not
know about that uh was was was full of
really that depressed that
self-destructive as a family didn't know
no I don't know and I you know I
certainly don't blame them for what he
did but I wonder why I wonder why they
were speculating about murder if he was
so obviously depressed and suicidal and
someone who's hospitalized three times
in three years with suicidal thoughts I
you know that's someone who very very
clearly has suicidal tendencies and is
struggling you know with with with many
internal struggles in any case put his
family aside the behavior from the media
and the Democrats in the left was just
grotesque and disgusting and soulless
they were all more than happy to take
advantage of this tragic situation for
their own ends these are this is truly
evil behavior again there was never any
reason to speculate that this was
anything other than a suicide the idea
that someone could have been could have
been lynched by a literal lynch mob in
public and nobody witnessed it and
there's no video or anything and no
evidence left behind is patently
ludicrous now I believe that some of the
people in the outraged mob some of some
of them might be dumb enough to actually
think that that's possible but elected
Democrats like Camela Harris for example
who's who was talking about this and
speculating especially someone like her
was it who you know is familiar with
with law enforcement she knows better
they they all knew better and yet they
were stoking this fire anyway if they
had a soul I would say they should feel
shame but they don't so they won't
number two here's a video of what guts
really looks like not literal guts I'm
not you know this is not a
video someone who's been disemboweled I
mean you have to clarify those sorts of
things these days now this is what
courage looks like I should say bravery
here you go
[Applause]
that's bold okay walking into a mob like
that with that sign that's great said
Savannah Hernandez by the way that's her
name
credits where it where it's due awesome
awesome stuff they're number three I
wanted to mention this maybe you've seen
the video footage this is Philip banks
former wide receiver retired military
caught up caught a baby that was tossed
thirty feet out of a burning building in
Phoenix if you haven't seen it watch the
footage here that's harrowing footage
heroic effort by mr. banks there and the
reason I'm playing is I've seen this all
over the internet you probably have
already seen it III think it's not being
emphasized enough if you have seen this
maybe you haven't even heard this part
of the story that the the baby was
thrown from the burning building by the
mother who saved the baby's life the
mother did not make it out she died in
the fire and she apparently died because
as I understand that she was going she
went back into the flames to retrieve
her daughter who she didn't realize had
already been rescued by a neighbor and
she but you know presumably was overcome
by by smoke inhalation and she died so
yeah it's a completely tragic story but
also in and banks who caught the child
that is a hero in this story and in you
know he's awesome but the the ultimate
hero of the story who I think we should
talk about honoring people should be
honored is the mother who gave her life
for her children you know that's that is
a tragic yet beautiful example of
motherly love so I wanted to play that
for you number four bill de blasio was
on with Wolf Blitzer yesterday when he
explained okay so
from the ultimate of courage to the
ultimate of gutless cowardice and that's
bill de blasio it was was on CNN he
explained that New York needs to go back
into a full lockdown
no large gatherings of any kind with one
exception can you guess what the
exception is so describe large events
for us what is what does that mean
it means like street fairs it means you
know big outdoor concerts and it means
things like parades
you know things here in the city can
mean not just thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people it's just not time for that now
what about protests if people want to
march down Fifth Avenue or they're gonna
be allowed to do so look a wolf this is
always an area of real sensitivity if
you're just talking about health we
would always say hey folks you know stay
home if you can but we understand this
moment in history people are talking
about the need for historic changes I
mean today in New York City you know
recognizing the power and the meaning of
the message black lives matter which we
did in front of Trump Tower today this
is a historic moment of change we have
to respect that but also say the people
the the kinds of gatherings were used to
the the parades the fairs we just can't
have that while we're focusing on health
right now not that this matters anymore
but that is just blatantly
unconstitutional that is a viewpoint
discrimination you you cannot do that
you can't tell people that they're only
allowed to gather if they're expressing
this or that point of view that that's a
just quintessential violation of the
Constitution there's there's no
discussion to be had a it would be hard
to think of a more blatant violation of
the First Amendment than that but he
there he's doing it anyway and that's
the thing you see that we can shout and
scream that something is like
unconstitutional those in power just
gonna do it anyway and that's what's
happening in New York 5 finally here's
footage out of Florida
giant stingrays are seen swimming by
unsuspecting beachgoers and you know you
you you you see that and you think okay
well there's the stingrays it's a pretty
big stingrays that's cool you know wow
look at those and those are big
stingrays so that's pretty cool stuff
interesting but then you see wait a
second what they bury delete lead there
well what is that is that Hellboy is
that is that Satan himself swimming in
the ocean that's some kind of mutant
human tomato half-breed no that's it
that's a person that's a full person
with the worst sunburn of all time
that is a 33rd degree sunburn that he
has his skin has melted off his body i
don't even that snot even his skin
that's just that's just that's the
insides of him he looks like he fell
into a vat of v8 juice or something that
the worst batman villain of all time
fell into a vat of v8 juice look at that
my god I thought I got bad sunburns
I burned pretty easily this dude's not
gonna be able to take a hot shower until
like next March sometime my goodness
wear your sunscreen kids wear the
sunscreen I'm a hypocrite because I
rarely wear it myself because I I just
enjoy the pain I guess masochist I don't
know but we're your sunscreens that's
that's the that's the real message there
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description